hola buenas tardes como tú muy bien lo
de Phineas fue un encuentro protocolar
que se extendió no obstante más de una
hora y media aquí en el Palacio de La
Moneda en el que el presidente saliente
Sebastián Piñera mostró las dependencias
de la manera
Patricia un día después del triunfo de
Boris los mercados precisamente
reaccionaron y reaccionaron a la baja el
peso chileno cayó ante el dólar
estadounidense y una buena parte de los
chilenos están felices por este triunfo
pero hay otro sector de la sociedad que
no lo está qué sensación hay un día
después de estos comicios que se
comentan las calles allí entre los
chilenos
bueno era muy esperada de esta caída en
la bolsa que ha reaccionado así en la
canción estanterías por ejemplo
ciclo que supone